now one of the things about sort of
being Johnny Depp is people must you
know want to come up and say hi they
want selfies and things and it's what do
have any sort of sympathy for me because
how young were you when you met Iggy Pop
your band was supporting him is that how
it what happened yeah I was 17 years old
we were on tour we did sort of did a lot
of opening act stuff you know around and
we were we had two shows with Iggy Pop
in Gainesville so I mean he was one of
my euros so I'm 17 years old we do the
gigs with Iggy it's a second night I
know he's splitting I'll never see him
again I want to meet him but I don't
want to go music I want to see I I
needed something different so I got in
caught you know in incoherent me drunk
pints is like vodka just to work up the
nerve to say something near the otic
which you shouldn't have to do so yeah
uh he was walking around with the beagle
I don't know why after the show you know
bites wrong he doesn't know why either
so I thought I'll get him and I just
started screaming he flop piggies flop
and a few other governors what you know
not sure what more rhymes with that so
he walked over to me with this being a
lot of leash and he got like that close
to my face I'm looking at him pops blue
eyes and takes so much time and he just
says you
to this day to these days one of the
best moments in my life
I walk over at this point I write oh god
maybe he won't remember me will be
humiliated about it to peon can't do any
form of bathroom like the guys who made
it we're like when she's a girl she
didn't go to the bathroom so standing up